Cái em thấy ở đây có những câu cô bố này ở đây
Các bố này ở đây ở đây tưởng tượngện nở rất là khó và tưởng trí nhiều bạn đập để cái em một tra hiểu gì
Và mắt luôn khu vẻ không để hiểu rồi thì mình sẽ tấn đam được muốn chi đã đập để muốn chiến
Là yệu câu năm này thì dễ ở tuy nhiên và là bài toàn rất là hay và sẵn tạo
Đúng tính chất tọn tế có só này thì...
Bố nó một bài toàn khó vài nó tinh bây hình ở Trung Dên này thì thì nó tinh bây hiểu tối hình học
E cả câu bố tối năm tô só rất là bài cuối khó nhất để tìm điều tối hình học
thì có xong này thì tính quá nó nhiều
thì tố này mình tảm rời thì chỉ dựa cho kém phút nền này của nhá
tảm rời tảm rời tảm rời tảm rời này nhiều